corona in deutschland es ist die siebte
woche die zahl der infizierten steigt
die folgen für mensch wirtschaft und
unseren alltag werden immer spürbarer
us-präsident trump verfügt ein
einreiseverbot für europäer in die usa
der deutsche aktienindex im freien fall
mehr als die hälfte der unternehmen
leidet bereits unter den folgen der
korona krise reisebüros hotels
gaststätten und kultureinrichtungen in
allen bundesländern wurden
großveranstaltungen abgesagt hier drohen
auch schulschließungen die großstadt
halle an der saale prescht vor alle
kitas und schulen sind ab jetzt für zwei
wochen dicht
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf spezial
die nachfolgenden sendungen verschieben
sich um zirka zwölf minuten
die stadt halle hat es getan
sie schließt ab morgen alle
bildungseinrichtungen bis ende märz
deutschlandweit allerdings gibt es keine
corona ferien so weit wollten die
kultusminister heute nicht gehen noch
nicht
das wirft fragen auf wie umgehen mit
dieser situation und was wenn einzelne
einrichtungen tatsächlich die kinder
nach hause schicken axel stein zeigt wie
unterschiedlich kommunen mit der
situation umgehen
gestern noch in der cd dass christian
wolff gymnasiums in halle an der saale
schüler niklas nimmt per handy teil am
englischunterricht von lehrerin
christiane müller niklas muss zu hause
bleiben 14 tage lang corona quarantäne
er war skifahren in südtirol und
langweilt sich jetzt ziemlich 24 stunden
später auch in halle es scheint er wirkt
etwas versonnen nachdenklich der branche
handel auf dem marktplatz sowie seine
hallenser heute denn der
oberbürgermeister hat verfügt schulen
kitas die uni alles wird geschlossen für
mindestens 14 tage
wir haben sieben infizierte und wir
haben uns sehr große mühe gegeben
diese infektionsketten dann auch
nachzuvollziehen sind in die dritte
vierte fünfte ebene hinein gekommen und
haben festgestellt dass was nicht mehr
kontrollieren kann das heißt diese
ebenen sind dann auch tätig zum teil den
universitäten in den schulen in den
harten und von daher war es von uns
nicht mehr steuerbar nicht mehr
steuerbar halle aber will handlungsfähig
bleiben produziert allerdings mit den
schul und kita schließungen einen
logistischen alptraum für eltern
wer passt jetzt während der arbeitszeit
auf die kleinen auf die oma die ganzen
umstände drumrum sind überhaupt nicht
geklärt
hier ist das jetzt mit der arbeit was
machen wir wenn schon die arbeits tätig
sind und jetzt das kind betreuen müssen
ich habe keine ahnung persönlich bin ich
da jetzt noch relativ locker weil ich
selber gerade nicht arbeiten gehen und
meine träger irgendwie betreuen kann
corona und die suche nach dem richtigen
krisenkonzept 60 kilometer entfernt in
leipzig hat man sich bewusst für den
anderen weg entschieden schulen und
kitas bleiben dort offen deutschland in
pandemie zeiten infektionsketten brechen
ansteckungsrisiken bewährten testzentren
einrichten alles gute ideen sicherlich
das scheint allerdings schlicht keine
einfache lösung zu geben
aus berlin zugeschaltet ist jetzt reiner
haseloff ministerpräsident von sachsen
anhalt guten abend benannt dem virus das
leben so schwer wie möglich machen das
ist das ziel
da trägt die entscheidung von heute die
schulen erstmal offen zu lassen aber
nicht wirklich dazu bei unterstützen sie
diese entscheidung der bürger informiert
und wir haben diese entscheidung auch
akzeptiert weil wir haben jetzt haben
gesundheitsamt vor ort entscheiden muss
ob mir ja die sache im griff behält es
ging ja gerade auch in dem bericht um
die steuerungsfähigkeit und deutschland
ist sehr heterogen in einer großstadt
spielt sich das leben anders aus als im
ländlichen raum und das merken wir auch
eine diskussion jetzt gerade eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
kanzlerin dass wir das problem haben
dass es eine einheitliche lösung nicht
geben kann aber wir nach einer klicken
schema arbeiten wollen bayern wird
sicherlich eine andere herausforderung
zu bewältigen haben als mecklenburg
vorpommern oder sachsen anhalt und in
sachsen-anhalt eben ein oberzentrum eine
großstadt
anders als ein landkreis in der altmark
und dazu werden wir in den nächsten
tagen entsprechende entscheidungen
treffen gemacht morgen einen sonder
kabinett werden dass man heute auswerten
was wir hier mit der kanzlerin
besprochen haben wichtig ist dass es
eine klare kette gibt zwischen dem
bundeskanzleramt der bundeskanzlerin den
landesregierungen dem
ministerpräsidenten und damit also auch
zu den landräten und die frage stellen
sich viele ist es nicht eine frage der
zeit bis dann doch alle schulen
geschlossen werden und wäre es nicht
sinnvoll so früh wie möglich damit jetzt
anzufangen haben wir müssen eine
abwägung treffen denn letztendlich ist
ja auch das personal in den
krankenhäusern wichtig und wenn wir
jetzt schlagartig alles und ohne
vorbereitung schließen würden dann
bringen wir uns um unsere
gesundheitsvorsorge möglichkeiten
entscheidend ist ja dass wir den kranken
helfen können dass wir neben der
prophylaxe vor allen dingen auch immer
noch lage sind auch die akut
behandlungen durchzuführen und das muss
gut überlegt werden nachhaltige sagt
reagiert aber alles andere muss jetzt
mit den landräten und bürgermeistern in
ruhe besprochen werden in den nächsten
tagen wird es dann sukzessive weitere
entscheidungen treffen zu treffen sein
und die bundesländer werden
wahrscheinlich auch andere
entscheidungen in den nächsten tagen
treffen als möglicherweise nachbarländer
denn in nordrhein westfalen und in
bayern haben wir wesentlich mehr fälle
als zum beispiel
im norden oder osten ganz kurz die
letzte frage viele entscheidungen werden
ja auf die kommunalen behörden verlegt
da liegen sie wie sich jetzt stellen sie
sicher dass diese entscheidung auch
richtig gefällt werden das ist ja weit
reichende maßnahmen wieder entschieden
werden die gesundheits andere sind
kompetent sie haben erfahrung und sie
haben auch eine klare fachlicher
anleitung auf der anderen seite das
haben wir heute auch festgestellt muss
es eine durch koordinierung von berlin
über die landeshauptstädte der
landesregierung bis in die kommunale
ebene geben die grund raster müssen
stehen und da muss individuell je nach
bedarf entschieden werden damit
möglichst die spitze abgebrochen wird
wir müssen den vorgang strecken damit
wir die chancen haben mit unseren
ressourcen auch wirklich die erkrankten
dann zu behandeln damit soll sich so
geht in italien
herr ministerpräsident vielen dank
corona in deutschland und jeden tag neue
nachrichten die uns alle herausfordern
heute wieder die usa so ist beschlossene
sache wird keine flugzeuge aus der eu
mehr ins land lassen
schon vor dieser meldung war der wert
vieler unternehmen an der börse gefallen
aber auch mittelständler und kleine
betriebe alle haben mit den folgen der
korona krise richtig zu kämpfen
fehlende lieferungen fehlende
bestellungen fehlendes vertrauen das
bringt unternehmen in not jürgen
wollmann berichtet eine region in
aufregung die eigentlich von der ruhe
lebt murnau am staffelsee im
voralpenland die touristen bleiben weg
absagen die die existenz bedrohen
selbst die große hotels mit
internationalem ruf
die lage ist wirklich dramatisch
man kann sich das nicht vorstellen
unsere umsätze sind zwischen 50 und 80
prozent teilweise 90 prozent hier im
land eingebrochen
und wir sehen uns einer völlig neuen
situation gegenüber auf die wir so
schnell gar nicht reagieren können
eigentlich machen die menschen genau das
was politik und wissenschaft empfehlen
zu hause bleiben
nicht anders geht es den
konzertveranstaltern die warnungen vor
großereignissen zeigen wirkung
das bekommt auch andreas schätzl von
münchen musik zu spüren
tausende verunsicherter kunden
walsh turnieren wir wissen heute noch
nicht was wir morgen spielen können und
dadurch ist nicht auch die einschätzung
dessen wie groß der schaden sein wird
noch gar nicht abgeschlossen aber es
werden auf jeden fall allein für
unternehmen wie uns mehrere millionen
sein
eine ganze branche in der existenzkrise
münchen musik habe keine versicherung
sagt der geschäftsführer
das wäre zu teuer und eine pandemie mit
einem neuen virus sei auch kaum zu
versichern so andreas schätzl die firma
bleibt auf ihren verlusten sitzen
die ganze krise bereits einmal durchlebt
das hat die bayerische firma webasto
hier wurde am 27 januar der erste
cholera fall in deutschland bestätigt
und die firma reagierte drastisch und
sehr schnell schickte alle mitarbeiter
zwei wochen in heimarbeit
das wichtigste ist geschwindigkeit
schnell die person in den diffizilen
schnell die kontaktpersonen 1 in den
diffizilen und am besten zentral testen
und zwar wichtig dass wir erst mal
unsere mitarbeiter sehr transparent
informieren sodass wir auch unnötige
ängste von vornherein im keim ersticken
heimarbeit die arbeitsstätte schließen
ein modell bei weitem nicht für alle wie
die tourismusbranche durch die krise
kommt ist noch nicht abzusehen
über die auswirkungen auf die deutsche
wirtschaft und den einreise stopp in die
usa darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
muscle kreutzer leiter des deutschen
instituts für wirtschaftsforschung
guten abend nach frankfurt guten abend
herr fahrzeug ein flugzeug aus der eu
darf mehr in die usa fliegen gilt am
morgen erst einmal für 30 tage
eine weitreichende entscheidung was
bedeutet das für die deutsche wirtschaft
es ist ein weiterer schritt der
eskalation der natürlich dazu führt dass
lieferketten immer stärker unterbrochen
werden dass auch menschen mittlerweile
ihren geschäften nicht mehr wirklich
nachgehen können wir sehen es innerhalb
europas genauso und das heißt letztlich
dass die wahrscheinlichkeit einer
rezession auch in deutschland
immer größer wird und ich halte sie für
unvermeidbar und jetzt geht es darum wie
stark wir die rezession sein was kann
die politik tun sich dem
entgegenzustellen
darüber wird er schon viel gesprochen
über hilfen für die wirtschaft also
kurzarbeitergeld abschaffung des solis
förderkredite alles maßnahmen die die
lage etwas erleichtern sollen für die
unternehmen reicht das aus ihrer sicht
aus nein es reicht noch nicht reicht bei
weitem noch nicht auch die reaktion der
finanzmärkte zeigt das ja sehr deutlich
dass das vertrauen nicht da ist dass das
wirklich ausreicht natürlich sind viele
richtige maßnahmen kurzarbeitergeld
überbrückungskredite aber es muss ein
wirkliches konjunkturprogramm kommen
dass deutlich mehr auch dem konsumenten
mehr geld in den taschen gibt wo der
staat auch ein klares signal setzt also
hier muss mehr passieren den
zentralbanken alleine werden es nicht
leisten können sondern die politik ist
hier in der pflicht
nach sieben wochen corona in deutschland
und immer wieder neuen maßnahmen die
handel reisen und dass auch normale
leben einschränken
wie sehr sehen sie die deutsche
wirtschaft generell unter druck die
deutsche wirtschaft ist unter enormen
druck wir haben auch erst den anfang
gesehen es wird sicher ausweiten
die quarantänemaßnahmen also wir haben
noch bei weitem nicht das ende der
fahnenstange erreicht die deutsche
wirtschaft ist besonders exponiert weil
sie sehr offen ist sehr abhängig von
exporten ist und das bedeutet wir der
kritische punkt ist wirklich die zeit
wann wird das virus unter kontrolle
gebracht wann können unternehmen wieder
anfangen normal zu funktionieren
das ist die kritische frage und die
antwort weiß im augenblick niemand aber
sie hängt auch davon ab wie die politik
handelt und wie entschieden sie sich
jetzt auch wirtschaftlich dem entgegen
steht sagt marcel fritsche leiter des
deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung vielen dank für
ihre einschätzung sehr gerne
genauso ansteckend wie das virus ist die
angst die verunsicherung das zeigt nicht
nur der blick in die wirtschaft auch im
alltag nehmen wir das ja alle zunehmend
war
alle vorsichtsmaßnahmen aber in
deutschland mögen sie noch so ungelegen
daherkommen haben ein ziel zeit gewinnen
das virus bremsen
dafür sollten wir in den nächsten tagen
und wochen viel verständnis haben
vielen dank für ihr interesse wie geht
es jetzt weiter mit notruf hafenkante
machen sie's gut und ihnen noch einen
schönen amt
[Musik]
um sie und rufen
ein einsatz für das team von notruf
hafenkante
was genau ist passiert gleich im zdf
menschen ließen ihr vater gestorben er
hat eine sehr schwarze dollar dinge
zuständig war ich hab so ein komisches
film den schaller ins ziel kam
[Musik]
samstag 20 15